6 13 is the time nearly half of the
country's tap water could be
contaminated with potentially toxic
compounds known as pfest or forever
chemicals it's from a recent study in
the U.S Geological Survey the chemicals
are used in products like non-stick
cookware and cosmetics they've been
linked to an increased risk of a number
of health problems so to try and
mitigate the effect the environmental
working group released a report looking
at which water filters can block the
chemicals and some well-known Brands
considered not effective others however
stood out
they actually reduced pfas down to
non-detectable levels which is really
great
and the price point was pretty low so in
the study pitchers from clearly filtered
and zero water blocked a hundred percent
of those pfas that were tested those are
about 25 or 30 bucks on Amazon but
here's the thing for these pitchers to
work properly you have to consistently
change out the filters meantime the EPA
is now considering rules that would
restrict the amount of pipas in our tap
water six four